I mean I don't know what's going to
happen this is not going to be a race
between Joe Biden and Donald Trump
here's a black pill from Tucker Carlson
so they've done everything they can by
legal means which are in fact extra
legal means if we're being totally
honest completely Third World stuff to
take the opponent out of the race and
they're still
losing so I mean I don't know what's
going to happen this is not going to be
a race between Joe Biden and Donald
Trump I would bet my beloved camp in
Maine that that is not going to happen
that's not going to happen so what will
happen well I don't know one of like 400
distinct other possibilities I mean I
just can't even you know pick one by the
way if it's Gavin Newsome we all should
be very very concerned that guy's scary
and I mean it I mean it
scary yeah but that's a whole separate
conversation but the point is this is
this will be forced these issues will be
forced soon like in a
year and the road from here to no
November of 2024 is going to be filled
with developments nobody in this room
could foresee I can promise you that so
it's about to get very serious for sure
miss you know it's only leadership of
the world at stake which is also by the
way we now know the most lucrative
possible political franchise in human
history so everything's a SI what
wouldn't they do what haven't they done
what might they do next let your
imagination run wild so the question the
only one that you can answer is how will
you
prepare yourself for that so that's what
we call the black pill right the black
pill of course is that things are really
out of control and they seemingly will
get worse the white pill is the last
line that he said What will what will
you do about it and I actually believe
that as crazy as it might get right
whether whether they push Biden over and
then the day after he's you know sworn
in once again they somehow replace him
with Gavin or whether they get Gavin in
first or they do some trickery with Cala
or all the tricks they could do or
whether they put whether or not I think
Trump is the best Republican to be
president right now whether they put
whether they allow Trump to run or
whether they stole the election or what
all of those things those are that's a
lot of stuff that is beyond your
day-to-day life right you can care you
can fight you can wake up you can do all
of the things that I always talk about
on this
show but you can take a little more
power also within your personal life and
there's one thing you can do really more
than anything else and now dare I flash
back to Dave Rubin in April of 2020
doing a video for prageru entitled The
Bravery deficit because you do have some
power but you have to exercise it here's
the good news if you currently reside in
the United States of America you live in
the freest country in the history of the
world Beyond some basic limitations you
can do whatever you want and with hard
work become whatever it is you want to
be pretty great ain't it so why the long
face because you know that something is
is out of whack you really don't feel
free to say what you want or share your
true thoughts on Facebook or even
associate with those you'd like to and
why is that I'll tell you why because
there's a mass Affliction spreading
throughout the Western world it's called
The Bravery deficit people good people
like you are afraid to say what they
think and there's Little Wonder so what
can you do believe it or not the
solution is not that hard step one think
for yourself step two say it out loud
don't take the path of least resistance
be better than those who would silence
you deplatform you and MOB you how just
stop being
afraid man we got to get that guy on the
show could someone reach out to him I
mean talk about somebody making some
sense over a serious you know course of
time it's all it's all there you guys
get it guys speak up share videos tell
your friends what you think like wake up
more
people